So last night was the second and final presidential
debate.
And I have to tell you, for me, being so desensitized
to this stuff being so used to what we see
and hear from politicians, it is actually
an outlier.
It really is a debate that was superlative
compared to other debates in a number of different
ways.
Number one, Joe Biden did really well.
I didn't expect Joe Biden to come out in the
way we did.
I knew he would say things that would make
sense, but I didn't imagine that he was going
to be from a tone and optics perspective.
So strong in comparison to Donald Trump.
I also didn't imagine that Donald Trump was
going to come out almost despondent and barely
able to even respond to Joe Biden's attacks
for the first 70 percent of the debate, the
last 30 percent going to conspiracy theories
and saying things that don't make any sense.
And it was one of the most uneven debates
I can imagine watching.
I thought back to 2012, the famous Obama Romney
debate where Romney made kind of a fool out
of himself, starting to say things that didn't
make sense and then trying to get Obama to
concede something.
And Obama just sitting there casually saying,
please proceed, Governor.
And it was very uneven.
But Romney's performance was better than Trump's
last night.
And Joe Biden just landing brutal hit after
hit on Trump.
Trump seemed almost slowed down, depressed,
confused, looked like he was taking physical
punches rather than simply metaphorical ones
in the first debate.
Biden wasn't nearly as strong as I'd like
to see.
And Trump was kind of annoying with his childish
interruptions, but it was not so lopsided.
Last night's debate stunningly one sided.
So let's look at some clips.
One quick note.
Excellent job by moderator Kristen Welker.
She had total control of the debate the entire
time.
There was no point at which she was in the
Chris Wallace position of almost having to
beg Trump to stop interrupting.
She in full control of the entire debate.
Very, very good to see.
And even from the get go, I mean, Trump entering
with no mask.
Joe Biden with a mask.
All emblematic, a microcosm of the entire
portion of the debate about Corona virus,
which was as usual and as I expected, one
of the worst parts of the debate for Donald
Trump.
Trump immediately trying to defend his work
on Corona virus, defending the indefensible
and predictably making no sense, talking about
what he's been able to do with goggles and
how other world leaders have praised him.
We have a problem that's a worldwide problem.
This is a worldwide problem.
But I've been congratulated by the heads of
many countries on what we've been able to
do with the.
If you take a look at what we've done in terms
of goggles and masks and gowns and everything
else and in particular ventilators, we're
now making ventilators all over the world,
thousands and thousands a month, distributing
them all over the world.
Joe Biden shot out of a cannon, immediately
says, listen, any president who oversees 220000
deaths, they can't continue to be president.
You don't reelect someone on the heels of
such a failure.
Two hundred twenty thousand Americans dead.
You hear nothing else I say tonight to this,
anyone who is responsible for not taking control.
In fact, not saying I'm I take no responsibility
initially anyone is responsible for that.
Many deaths should not remain as president
of the United States of America.
We're in a situation where there are a thousand
deaths a day now, thousand deaths today, and
there are over 70000 new cases per day compared
to what's going on in Europe.
As the New England Medical Journal said, they're
starting from a very low rate.
We're starting from very high rate.
The expectation is we'll have another two
hundred thousand Americans dead time between
now and the end of the year for just war,
these mass.
The president's own advisers told him we could
save one hundred thousand lives.
And we're in a circumstance where the president
thus far is still has no plan, no comprehensive
plan.
So really not a good start for Donald Trump.
And it got even worse.
Donald Trump tried pulling this thing about.
I shut down travel from China and Biden said
I was xenophobic.
And Biden with this was when I thought, Joe
is really ready.
Biden with a perfect line which says you are
xenophobic, but not because you shut down
travel from China.
Our response is he is xenophobic.
But not because he shut down access from China
and he didn't lead after 40 countries had
already done that.
In addition to that, what he did, he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in there
in China trying to get the bullhorn to determine
what exactly the source was.
What did the president say in January?
He said no.
He said this is he's being transparent.
The president of China is being transparent.
We owe a debt of gratitude.
We are.
We have to thank him.
This is when in watching Trump just stand
there shaking his head.
I realize this was not during the muted microphone
phase of the debate.
I realized Trump didn't have it.
Trump was not up to the task last night.
And indeed, this is where it really started
going off the rails.
Trump, in trying to defend his record, bizarrely
goes into talking about Joe Biden's basement.
And Joe Biden making money that I guess Trump
thinks is not appropriate money for Joe Biden
to have made your reaction over soon.
I say we're learning to live with it.
We have no choice.
We can't lock ourselves up in a basement like
Joe does.
He has the he has the ability to lock himself
up.
I don't know.
He's obviously made a lot of money someplace,
but he has this thing about living in a basement.
People can't do that, by the way.
I as the president couldn't do that.
I'd love to put myself in the basement.
So that's an example of Trump throwing a punch
that just missed everything.
Like, it just hit nothing.
And Joe Biden, in a bunch of these moments,
Joe Biden just smiled and laughed.
And I think that's the right way to brush
off Trump.
Silly, conspiratorial ad hominem, because
if you try to deal with it directly, I don't
know how you do it without sounding defensive.
Pete Buddah judge on Fox News has had some
good examples of when he's put on the defensive
and he hits back and it doesn't seem like
he's on the defensive.
He's he's back to offense.
I just don't know that Biden would have been
able to do it in this format without actually
seeming defensive, which you don't necessarily
want to do.
So I think Biden just laughing this stuff
off was was perfect.
That's the right way to do it.
Joe Biden then going after Rudy Giuliani,
not mentioning the Borat fiasco, but mentioning
many other things that triggered Donald Trump.
Well, his buddy, Rudy Giuliani, he's being
used as a Russian pawn.
He's being fed information that is Russian.
That is not true.
And then what happens?
Nothing happens.
And then you find out that everything is going
on here about Russia is wanting to make sure
that I do not get elected the next president
on his face because they know I know them
and they know me.
So Trump also unable to take that on.
And then again, Donald Trump saying when the
topic of his taxes came up, that now his line
is he prepaid millions of dollars at the town
hall.
When Trump asked about paying 750 in taxes,
Trump said, well, that's a statutory amount.
That's like a minimum fee, almost like you
pay when you file.
And my my accountant said I paid.
That didn't make any sense.
Now we have a different story, which is he
actually prepaid millions of dollars.
And I guess that's why they're not on his
return.
It's impossible to decipher what he's talking
about.
None of it is believable.
And then this is where it almost seemed like
Trump was was unaware of his surroundings
and not even understanding what he was saying.
He starts using this mafia aske language to
accuse Biden of giving money to the big men.
Nobody could understand what he was talking
about.
So I called my accounts, underwrote it.
I'm going to release them as soon as we can.
I want to do it and it'll show how.
Successful how great this company is.
But much more importantly than that, people
were saying 750 dollars.
I asked them a week ago.
I said, what did they pay?
They said, Sir, you prepaid tens of millions
of dollars.
I prepaid my tax tense over the last number
of years, tens of millions of dollars I prepaid
because at some point they think it's an estimate.
They think I may have to pay tax.
So I already prepaid it.
Nobody told me that your account.
But I tell you that.
Excuse me.
And it wasn't written whenever they write
this.
They keep talking about seven hundred and
fifty dollars, which I think is a filing fee.
But let me just tell you, I prepaid millions
and millions of dollars in taxes.
Number one.
Number two, I don't make money from China.
You do.
I don't make money from Ukraine.
I don't make money from Russia.
You made three and a half million dollars.
You and your son gave you.
They even have a statement that we have to
give 10 percent to the big man.
You're the big man, I think.
I don't know.
Maybe not.
Trump continuing to say, by the way, five
years later, he can't release his taxes, even
the ones from, I guess, like 2012 at this
point because he's under audit or audit, as
Trump often says.
And then again, Trump saying Biden gives money
to the big men.
One of the most incoherent attacks of the
night, Joe Biden just saying this is really
simple.
Show us the returns to talk about this more
broadly.
Respond very quickly and then I'll get to
my question.
Why do you.
He's been saying this for four years.
Show us.
Just show us.
Stop playing around.
You've been saying for four years you're going
to issue taxes.
Nobody knows.
Mr. President, what they do know is you're
not paying your taxes or you're paying taxes
that are so low.
When last time he said what he paid, he said,
I only pay that little because I'm smart.
I know how to game the system.
Come on.
Come on, folks.
Come on, man.
Becoming a very, very popular meme from this
debate.
Come on, man.
I know this is a really special moment because
Trump tries a Hunter Biden conspiracy and
refers to some very strong e-mail.
And Joe Biden perfectly explains that Americans
pay tariffs that Trump put on China.
Trump still doesn't understand how tariffs
work.
Let me know.
I have to respond to that.
OK.
Very quickly.
And then we're going to move on.
I have dollars from China, Doddridge ever
Vendig 10 minutes in office and being an Air
Force Two, number one.
Number two, there's a very strong e-mail talking
about your family wanting to make 10 million
dollars a year for introductions.
President Trump on China policy, though, don't
know.
What are you gonna do?
What specifically are you going to do to make
China pay?
You've said your personal John is paying.
They're paying billions and billions of dollars.
I just gave twenty eight billion dollars.
So since I just gave twenty eight billion
dollars to a farmers tax on.
That's why taxpayers money didn't I know the
taxpayers?
It's called China.
China pays for 28 billion.
And you know what they did to pay Joe?
They devalued their currency.
And they also paid up.
Look at how this is four years into the presidency.
And Donald Trump still thinks that when you
tariff China, Chinese people send the United
States Treasury money.
No, our companies, when they import things
from China, pay the tariffs.
The money comes from American companies.
And I've said before, I don't know if Trump
still doesn't understand that or is pretending
not to understand it when the topic of health
care came up.
Trump started talking about Joe wants socialized
health care.
He's going to destroy Medicare and Social
Security, none of which is true, some of which
we wish were true.
But it's not.
Biden astutely pointing out you're running
against me.
I beat those other people.
Why are you talking about other people's policies
when he says public option?
House talking about socialized medicine.
And when he and and healthcare.
When he talks about a public option, he's
talking about destroying your Medicare totally
district and destroying your Social Security.
And this whole country will come down.
You know, Bernie Sanders tried it there, his
state.
He tried it in his state.
His governor was a very liberal governor.
They want to make it work.
OK, let's hear.
It was my hospital might work.
It does.
This president, but very confused guy.
He thinks he's running against somebody else.
He's running gets Joe Biden.
I beat all those other people because I disagreed
with them.
Joe Biden, he's running against Joe Biden,
quickly lining up retorts to all attacks.
Which was great to see.
Wasn't ready in the first debate on that front.
This was maybe the worst moment of the debate
for Trump.
Trump again pulling out this line of attacking
so-called Democrat cities and states, which
is a message of complete division.
And and this this was pitch perfect.
Joe Biden perfectly responding to that divisive
message, saying, listen, I'm not going to
talk about blue states and red states.
I'm a Democrat running for president.
I will be the president for everybody, regardless
of what state you're in.
Couldn't have teed it up any better for Joe
Biden.
There was really a big bailout for badly run
Democrats, cities and states.
All right.
I want to get elected.
I'm not going to I'm running as a proud Democrat.
I could be an American president.
I don't see red states and blue states.
What I see as American United States and folks,
every single state out there finds himself
in trouble.
They're going to start laying off whether
they're red or blue.
Cops, firefighters, first responders, because
teachers, because they have to balance their
budget.
And you see Trump just kind of nodding and
shaking his head like a fool during that one.
Even Trump seemed to realize that attacking
half the country when you're depending on
a handful of key battleground states to win,
which are very much split blue, red, Democrat,
Republican, not a good idea.
The next worst moment for Trump was when he
casually went xenophobic.
The topic of immigration came up.
And Trump had no choice, I guess, in his mind,
in order to really own Biden than to talk
about low IQ, Hispanic immigrants, just really
bottom of the barrel stuff here.
Only the really I hate to say this, but those
with the lowest IQ, they might come back.
President Ronald Reagan, Vice President Biden,
a chance to respond.
And then we're gonna move on to the don't
know.
Vice President Biden, your response.
And then one hilarious moment.
Was Trump calling himself the best president
for black people since Abe Lincoln?
And Joe Biden sarcastically came back and
said, you know, Abe Lincoln over here hasn't
done this.
That and the other thing, Trump doesn't understand
it.
Trump doesn't understand humor.
Trump doesn't understand satire.
It's actually sociologically the most interesting
moment.
We talk about how Trump has no sense of humor.
He doesn't seem to get jokes.
Trump is actually visibly confused by this
joke and asks what Joe Biden is talking about.
It.
Let me ask you very quickly and then I have
a follow up question for you.
Abraham Lincoln.
Here's one of the most racist presence we've
had in modern history.
He pours fuel on every single freshest fire,
every single one started off his campaign
coming down the escalator saying is getting
rid of those Mexican rapists.
He's banned Muslims because they're Muslims.
He has moved around and made everything worse
across the board.
He says to them about the poor boys.
Last time we were on stage three, said, Thomas,
stand down and stand ready.
Come on.
This guy is a dog whistle about as big as
a foghorn.
President Trump, I'm going to give you 10
seconds to respond.
And then I have I made a reference to Abraham
Lincoln.
Where did that come in?
I mean, you said Abraham Lincoln.
Where did that?
No, no, I said not since Abraham Lincoln.
Has anybody done what I've done for the black?
And I'm sad to say I'm Abraham Lincoln.
I said not since Abraham Lincoln.
Has anybody done what I've done for the black.
This is just so funny.
And Biden can't help but laugh.
Trump doesn't understand satire.
It's lost on him.
I don't know what Trump understands, less
satire or how tariffs work.
He seems to not understand either of them.
And then final, stunning moments after the
end of the debate, we saw Melania Trump and
Jill Biden walk onto the stage.
Melania approaching Donald Trump.
They seem to barely even say a word to each
other.
They look miserable.
Trump not putting a mask on.
Joe Biden immediately puts a mask on at the
end of the debate, emblematic of their respective
perspectives on Corona virus.
Jill Biden embraces Joe Biden.
They look like a normal couple.
The Trump's look miserable Biden.
Both Jill and Joe Biden try to catch Trump
and Melania's eye to say bye to wave bye.
Trump doesn't even acknowledge the Biden's
presence on stage.
The Biden's wave trump start just walking
off and then you see it's either Malani or
ripping her hand out from Trump's hand or
vice versa, but just completely emblematic
of everything that these people represent.
So a terrible debate for Donald Trump.
The way I would summarize it, if you if you
said how does it how do you distill what happened?
Trump spent 90 minutes talking about his problems,
whereas and his victimhood and his being a
martyr.
While Joe Biden talked about the problems
affecting the American people rather than
about Joe Biden himself.
And if you have ever seen a more lopsided
presidential debate, let me know, because
I can't remember one.
We've got just a little over a week left until
this election.
Trump is going to try funny business to win
it.
We are at the election, 40, 45 million people
have already voted.
That's about a third of the expected electorate
or more.
Let's do it.
This is it.
There's nothing else to wait for.
No more debates.
You can vote now in a vast majority of states,
either by mail or early.
Let's just do it.
And let me know your thoughts about the debate
in these last 10 days on Twitter, where you
can find me
at David Pakman.